like I remember doing it with this girl
and I'm licking on her ear she's got a
ear infection from the earrings what
that's worst case scenario I was licking
all over that beging away did it taste
funny did it taste like metal I was so
horny but here the worst here's the
worst part sensing a theme we finished
whatever
philanthropic I'm sick so sick for like
a week just vomiting no you're licking
her blood I was vomiting orange and I
was dying dude she had an ear infection
I probably drank ear infection the
infection didn't like turn you off you
know how some people see red when
they're mad yeah I see pink when I'm
horny love baby girl was like can you
put on some depend diaper you said yes
to that just a what do think of course
he did you got depends on you like that
though like Joe had it in his trunk or
grandparents do you have to play the
role of like a baby or something he's
like no I just wore the diaper I didn't
play
the I just p on and went to sleep